yeah you drink enough of that
everything's got to be great again so
BuzzFeed apparently spent $200 on this
discontinued rum vodka so that we could
drink it today
this one's from vodka
I didn't know Trump had a vodka I guess
he kind of looks like he just took a
shot that look like his skin color
hahahaha the world's finest produced and
bottled by where the Netherland thats on
America it's probably gonna taste like
misogyny inequality this vodka is going
to taste like self-tanner
free free hi we it's a quarter ooh do I
have to do all that that was a lot uh oh
there you go yeah I can do that tears
I'm so afraid that is surprisingly good
oh oh that burns like a UTI Trump vodka
putting the tea back in the UTI
it tastes like a mix in between a
expensive vodka and a cheap vodka yeah
it's a good it's not $200 good I
wouldn't pay not to drink this this may
be hard to believe but I've actually had
worse vodka than this in my life I would
do another shot of this I hate to say
just for you Internet oh we need to
build build a wall around this so it
doesn't hurt anybody ever again